a national scandal is unfolding before
our eyes
which is not unusual these days as an
entire generation of students
is being conned out of a real education
by unscrupulous and greedy teachers
unions
hell bent on using the pandemic to their
advantage as a result
schools all over our country are still
shut down
and kids have been forced into online
learning
and the cost has been staggering for
instance
in los angeles schools saw a sharp drop
in kindergarten enrollment about 6 000
students
in saint paul minnesota 40 percent of
high school students
have failing grades you guys 40 percent
and even
even higher percentage of kids in
houston texas
are failing at least two classes in our
nation's capital
there's been a 14 percentage point drop
among black students in kindergarten
through second grade
who met literacy standards and just 20
miles away in fairfax county virginia
a new survey of academic performance in
schools
found that f letter grades are up are
you ready for this you guys
83 percent this year for fairfax middle
schoolers
it's even worse f's are up 300 percent
this is right not going from pandemic's
disruption to your children's education
to your jobs and incomes and to your
other caregiving responsibilities
has been tremendous we also could not be
prouder of how our students and staff
have stepped up to learn
and to teach in new ways and how
everyone has adapted to these challenges
wow how everyone has adapted right this
is not like going from a b
student to a c student here this system
is literally
failing the students children are being
left behind
special needs students can't get the
help they need
yet the teachers unions want the schools
to stay closed
of course those very same teachers
unions will see an even
more power framework under the biden
administration
we win this election we're going to get
the support
you need and the respect you deserve you
don't just have a partner in the white
house
you'll have an nda member in the white
house
well that should be concerning to some
people and joining me now
is osran omani fairfax county parent and
former
georgetown professor also with me is
cynthia garrett education activist
and founder of cynthia garrett
ministries and author of
i choose victory that is a great title
cynthia thank you both for joining me i
appreciate it
thank you now i was uh just in relating
that to our audience asura
the numbers are shocking uh we've we've
had a lot of shocking news this year
especially out of fairfax uh how are
parents
uh doing and isn't there i would think
that there might be an uprising or there
should be to deal with the entire school
board what's going on out there
oh parents are so angry i mean you can
see behind me we've got
the man that you just heard is scott
bray brand the superintendent of fairfax
county
parents now have this bumper sticker on
their cars through northern virginia
they have fire bray brand audit
fcps i was just so angry listening to
your
segment just now the data on these poor
kids
literally poor kids who are failing now
because we have a superintendent and a
school board that is failing our
children
scott brabrandt has famously said
through this year that
equity is at the heart of his uh
initiative
for fairfax county public schools and so
what he has done
is he has become an activist instead of
an educator
and what he is doing is failing the kids
that he's supposedly trying to reach
there's so much hypocrisy
usually the data is about three to four
percent for kids in middle school who
are failing
so right now the number of kids that are
economically disadvantaged and failing
is one out of five
wow hispanic kids one out of four the
english language learners
one out of three and our boys one out of
ten
that's unbelievable and so what we have
is a lost year just
as you said it's a political scandal
it's
it's a travesty and our superintendent
is making
more than 300 000 a year for this
remarkable performance
it's it's horrible it's it's just so
outrageous you know there are so many
different fronts to this
cynthia you've got the teachers unions
and political interests there
you've got the impact psychologically on
children
when if you get an f where if you fail
it at a young age it
you know this sets into motion attitudes
in a framework
uh in addition of course to the well uh
the people getting rich in this
framework as though we're
useless or we're throwaways uh what is
your take cynthia on
what parents can do considering the
long-term impact this isn't just
one year that's lost but the
psychological impact on children overall
well you're right tammy the
psychological impact is incredible
because
you and i both know that you know when
you get an f
and you're you get a failing grade the
word fail
is sort of on your forehead right so you
students tend to withdraw they they
become
more and more sort of resistant to even
learning
and then so the inequity gap has just
gotten
wider and wider so kids who are already
struggling now
they're way behind and i think so
much of what parents can do has
really has got to do with really and
truly getting upset
and showing up we've got to start to
show up
in our school rooms in the classrooms at
the board meetings we've got to show up
and we have to speak up and we have to
get angry and we have to start to demand
change well i'd like to look i'd like
both of you to hear a little bit about
what joe biden had to say
about the reopening of schools listen to
this for a second
what will you do to get kids back in
school how much will you be working the
phones and working with governors and
mayors it takes a lot of money to get
them back the estimates are
150 200 billion dollars for the year
would take to get
safely open our schools uh sir i mean
doesn't that say at all
suddenly it is about money about saving
money about
a bunch of things that really have
nothing to do with worrying about the
kids
and america in general is agreeing that
there's no reason to not have these
schools open
isn't that kind of a confession about
what this is really about
well what's lost in this is our children
i mean that's what's such a tragedy
in all of this right here is this book
that um
our superintendent paid twenty thousand
dollars to have its author speak for one
hour
our school district one hour just
imagine
that he's just putting in safety
mechanisms right now for our school
system
and yet failing our kids there's a young
man watching you tonight his name is
teddy
he woke up at 5 45 a.m for the last
uh sign up for the last school board
meeting because he wanted to beg
the superintendent and the school board
to open up schools he was so excited he
was going to go back a couple weeks ago
and on the eve of his return for
transitional
like a little experiment canceled school
was canceled
they're just playing around with kids
lives
and meanwhile they're going after the
social justice activism
my son goes to the high school scott
brabrand the superintendent
has been at war with this high school's
parents and students to change
admissions to quote
improve equity and yeah meanwhile he has
such
injustice in the way that he's actually
educating our kids
and so it's a failure they get an f
grade we and our kids
you should yeah we need to we need to
think about you know what is the biggest
factor
cynthia in school shutdowns we've got a
new
a study from the wisconsin institute for
law and liberty they found that the
presence of a teachers union
was more of a deciding factor for
wisconsin school districts
choosing to direct their classes
virtually not the extent of the pandemic
itself in the community
is you know that's apparently consistent
with national research
so what they're saying is this really
has nothing to do cynthia with science
uh or what's best for your kids would
what's your take on that
well we know it has nothing to do with
science i mean the science has always
said that children
are not really the ones at risk and so
i think that a lot of this in my
estimation i mean i look at it and
honestly i just go
well i know we've been lazy in our
school districts and i know that
there's been a lot of money thrown at a
at what's called the problem
fixing the problem but honestly part of
the problem i think
is that we have a lot of people who
really and truly like in some sense
what's going on yeah that may sound
harsh
but that's how i see it but that yeah i
think you're right that that's what a
lot of us have seen
it's a big question it's been eight
months uh this is now very serious
uh a lot of people are still being uh
moved through fear but ladies i want to
thank you because now this is about the
children right
this is about the next generation
long-term impacts ladies thanks for
being with us